yeah welcome to this video I'm doing a
war zone final and I'm late joining
about 2 minutes and we got a game
immediately I need to get rid of this
little window here okay South Queen's
Gambit let's try for some aggressive
stuff I actually have got to double the
this is counter gambit is quite
interesting Shara Shara Hideki shiny
gambit so it was that we had to
pronounce this in English fashion with
German names okay so he didn't take the
pawn or it can win the pawn on d5 now we
got some pretty standard looking
isolated pawn position where he's got
some strange pieces Queen and and Bishop
yeah uh-huh
I thought him he needed to take this now
looks tricky already for what attacking
the Queen and I have to spin and maybe I
also could have taken and played Bishop
g4 but Bishop g4 looks looks fine yeah
this this should run the Queen so check
here and queen is saying yeah just win
the Queen Queen you want okay oops okay
let's get back into a benoni
yeah this check is meant to to displace
this brush up a bit yeah it's a very
quick and playing on in this pad moose
f5 just gives away e6 don't believe this
should be any good but okay maybe it's
not so clear okay lucky one
yeah but this is a temple now and then
h6 is saying yeah it's a two-minute game
it's clear that you cannot spend huge
amounts of time but all this instant
moves don't help if you if you're just
so bad that you yeah this is a check
that you basically lose yeah and came
with a peace and also this night which
prevents the black king to to get to the
six bone and next I can just yeah yeah I
cannot do anything anyway I mean you
cannot leave a seven undefended is have
nine defend itself you cannot move
really now I'm getting you seven
so what's what's the quickest solution
yeah I can also just take this yeah b1
is defended and he ate okay I've got the
Queen first oops I actually thought this
was was it I would have better check hey
Brooke age seven nursemaid next just had
it wrong fish love the black king yeah
okay yeah it's gonna stay in that of
course yeah now disconnected what today
what an idiot
you had the typical idiot yeah playing
all moves instantly just blundering away
everything and then he disconnects to
cost me 40 seconds of time yeah great
yeah I really don't understand why they
not give you the point after let's say
10 seconds if you disconnect you
disconnect bad luck I mean bad luck if
you really have a disconnection issue
but if you're just just an idiot like
this guy I'll be I'll be frank here then
you should just give away the point much
quicker right French defense previous
lucky move 96 it's not so bad yeah
unfortunately he chose the driest and
dullest possible continuation with the
exchange in one d5 ok I try to make it a
bit more interesting but probably am
this is just a crap position ok not not
that I like to do this but what can you
do ya can
defender we can see it's not not very
comfortable get this two two double
pulse and some what we can okay mmm okay
I can play this I mean rook f3 I can
just take and have the idea of playing
rook g4 then Queen on f5 protects h7 so
rogue age 3 is not not the big issue
so let's activate okay yeah maybe he
sees some is some able to play f3 yeah
possible but if I go rook g8 f 3 I can't
actually take on g2 Queen f5 rook takes
H to mate yeah I don't I'm I'm actually
a threatening to take on c2 I have to
yeah either from V you cover dead but I
can take on f2 now right I hope so at
least
and that's also g2 now hanging if you
place g3 I take the rook
it looks pretty promising I also have
got rook h4 I just just recognized that
but book takes g2 should be should be
enough you know what Queen G to group g2
can go rook e8 and many okay then I'll
go here okay here this rook e8 Sam if I
take on g2 root 3 - Queen of uninsulated
you know this is just curtains on H -
okay so I'm place close to the top now
in this tournament
yeah the Englund gambit so very generous
opening giving a pawn for nothing and of
course that h6 isn't exactly the way to
try at least to get some compensation
I can't just develop this is just a
suicide mission I'm like Queen e5 a
queen h5 I'm sorry look so devastating
rook King d8 I just yeah I can just give
this check on f7 yeah don't take the
rook maybe he can shake on b2 okay
but 96 now it's a double check right
besides the fact that I can take the
rook
oh come on thanks for spending time here
it's not I'm not really efficient I'm
just preparing 95 let's let's Castle and
get the pieces into play
we should reform yeah this is nice
no needs to go to eh and still not [ __ ]
made probably not don't see one there is
no medium really you're amazing
let's get if you look into the attack as
well with Roop g3 yeah I'm losing so
much time on this in this game ok should
have just played much quicker maybe
taken the rook or something
I thought there there should be a
checkmate but I didn't I didn't see any
ok that's some threaten Rukh Khan g8
mate yeah now this is made Queen da da
Bishop FH you can just interpose some
material yeah this really cost lots of
time some guys on six six out of six I
got this guy earlier yeah I do you need
to climb tomorrow
I mean it's it's an interesting opening
but not very scary for black but I
always felt that it's a good idea to him
to deny white the kind of stuff that he
was sauce aiming for originally this
Marazzi kind of position is very often
something that white players them with a
gambit style don't feel so comfortable
we already see this he actually I'm
already a somewhat better with them the
great long diagonal for the for the
bishop it's a multiple yeah they're
multiple good news Bishop here on some
other maneuvers also would have been
good yeah let's get into the spent and
threatened Queen to f6 can be irritating
Queen f6 he maybe has got nine h5 ever
pongee five-year 1345 simply
yeah don't know why differ just if I
play a five
how does he how does he protect this
actually I can of course just take very
idiotic what the silly idea
cause he can just take oh man
f5 was really enjoyed move okay
yeah just any move and I'm pretty pretty
clearly better but this is just weakens
six and d5
I simply simply didn't take into account
that he can take on a five very very
very stupid yeah he's also maybe asking
myself what the heck is like doing here
my it's not what a catastrophe I still
have a good Bishop only five but it's
completely useless sooo to weaken your
position like that I didn't have any
weaknesses and how is six and d5 is just
stupid okay but okay I'm threatening
some stuff the light is hanging and yeah
what now
d3 is hanging needs to return I can just
take care if I want but sure this was a
good choice but let's threaten g4
I'm overlooking some very very simple
moves here maybe it's still ok taking
the Queen note ya know at the end III
saying yeah maybe it was still okay but
overlooked it's up very simple stuff we
came okay let's play one fo for change
and okay let's let's go for it smooth
more on myself
Oh actually I'm heading for this this
Siberian traps variation and I forgot
how it's working okay
it's something like that Wow
okay yeah I probably wants to play h4
yeah I cannot really believe this
probably miss a time okay but let's go
here the sugar should lead to quite some
attack at least threatening to check on
f7 you know take on f7 925 this is so
this is just just over for black Queen
f7 okay let's let's just take this book
if it is hanging and all kinds of stuff
yeah well you can g5h five no no I don't
think this is playable okay let's play
the curbs okay I don't want age five
maybe this isn't the best move that
mm-hmm yeah hard to believe that this
should be a bad for black I mean would
be fine and all this don't get this
often in them then only enter this is
essentially benoni well and now he
canceled too short interesting
yeah unknown then of course not yeah
besides III don't really play draws and
this tournaments I think that I'm just
better yeah he offered me this exchange
but I want to threaten Bishop take geez
reduces just need and can easily be
overlooked Knight f2 also as a threat if
you play some uh-huh okay retreated some
of the question is what now I've got
multiple good moves even taking just on
May one isn't bad ok let's first take
him and now think about this I mean it
can also I can also check here yet
probably this is the simplest
now go up here and I said oh no I can
can take here and have to smooth with G
for coming
this looks pretty dreadful for white
I hope and look at this one but still I
mean just this move okay what else I can
take here first and then play G for
right it takes a night 97 Wow
yeah some guys have all the luck oh but
we never ever intended this it's still
so very good for me
yeah the time of courses so the main
problem position is just winning can
just take your five nine even their
supreme move yeah not much that you can
do just just to slow in these
complications yeah this cost some time
okay yeah let's put a stage before and
what did not play it again this yeah
well the benoni is a good opening for
what usually okay yeah this is this is
quite interesting it's not played very
often but I always like this for white
heard like I'm pretty risk-free way to
to set up on slightly very slightly
better position like simply as captain
this somewhat awkward Bishop on e7 and
white is controlling d5
there's a threatening Quincy five I
think at least yeah Quincy five
oh this what yeah this this now is sound
very comfortable with them the dead
Bishop on f6 and I'm controlling all the
key squares d5 of courses the the main
weakness and the night as chances to
come to come to see 45 questions how to
get it there let's H 2 F 1 and so on
okay I went f6 yeah I made and maybe it
could have gone by H for a song okay
let's just grab the material and I was
also threatening queenie ate some didn't
really have anything okay it's a bad
piece but king opponent came with two
extra pawns isn't isn't so bad
yeah this is nice the early resigner for
a change
yeah I'm leading play this guy again I
had it before not quite sure what game
this was okay Scott game
and now which is supposed to a scotch
gambit yeah now chief is a rare line but
not a deadline oh I think it's t6 here
forgot forgot really how it is played
but this should be okay for black I'm
not totally totally wrong yeah those
kind of lines are sometimes a bit tricky
because you I mean they're not good for
white but you can sometimes just forget
the right moves and - with a little time
and sometimes it's irritating maybe just
taken 25 yeah this that there really are
a boatload of those crappy gambits but
yeah they're they're not good but they
are also good little time not not so
easy to refute and this is sometimes
really a problem okay let's go here
support your form I can take off those
pieces not bad yeah I've gotten an open
position now with little bishops some
black should be should be somewhat
better unless you you blunder stuff like
I just did okay maybe it's not so
terrible
Bishop f8 after Bishop takes c3 and it's
it's not clear maybe he and c5 could be
could be quite good
I can take a two also I hope bit worried
that the drive back rank is a bit weak
but I don't see a Bishop Bishop c5 mmm
possible maybe you should take c5 maybe
you can play that okay I want to make
sure that I'm not making it on the back
rank okay this is a check but um yeah
the C pawn okay he's in a long pin here
on rock d8 I can take with the Queen
which is not ideal but to him it's a
it's okay
no this was whom who finished I had just
managed with nothing on the clock
okay maybe not some player cuckoo piano
Italian game but less complicated okay
so I thought maybe f7 would be some some
idea to do something that wasn't
possible really came cannot want to try
to control d5 of course he ignores it
just instantly playing d5 I mean if I
was saying but maybe he's got some
compensation no idea
yeah okay let's let's take this and
catch up on with the development yeah
okay but maybe I can try to get the
bishop on d4 it's some pretty pretty
active post for the bishop I wanna just
see F for Bishop g4 Bishop b4 okay yeah
maybe I just should just try to exchange
rooks with Bishop d2
yeah Bishop b2 now he could could
actually take hmm I hope I'm not I'm
getting too passive here of course you
want to exchange material when when
you're when you're up a pawn or whatever
but you need to be conscious that you
don't give give up too much activity but
he gave me the default so it's probably
still you know still okay Queenie six
coming he has a system in some ways
similar to the to the Marshall gambit
it's a de-spawn down but I've got them
bamboo cookie six not sure if it would
do it anyway but I need to need to speed
up simply
right now I play this K root g5g for
okay okay and then then I take the root
also not bad yeah yeah some guys couple
of points ahead nine points yeah usually
we get a friendship
I've got played this this guy a numerous
times
Oh normally plays Bishop g5
h4 yeah it's fun what kind of stuff is
obviously a playable or at least yeah at
least it's played
I mean if it's good I doubt what yeah
this was mysterious okay okay that's
good default
mixing the moves and let's see what
happens after the jump off scheme no I
really don't understand those those draw
offers okay this guy is pretty high
rated I just just saw this too far
something still um I don't see why I
should draw army
I mean why not wanna play a game
okay so um probably the smooth intending
not a three to H form online a three to
control H form this g5 approaches of
course them yeah very crude but it can
be it can be effective I sometimes play
plate like this myself against the Trump
hmm not sure I have more than one good
continuation yeah it can take now and
detect this but I can play here and now
oops oops oops oops oops not so quick I
was intending rook h1 to be honest
and of course this is not working then I
need to take it still I'm not bad for me
okay so okay let's let's try here I
might h3i he plays f4
yeah I should have just taken of course
have you taken on g4 this is still good
for what you really okay
I thought thought you would yeah well
this is no no issue at all what is just
better the time is of course a problem
yeah 10 seconds is too too little I just
played this too slowly yeah it doesn't
really try to play good news anymore I
think Justin Kenyon to win on time yeah
can you seven my twins of course how
just just terrible
yeah we'll just just plain too slowly
and overlooking things the soul of
something was g5 was wrong yeah really a
joke dick okay
come on not exactly correct this this
kind of playing with them sometimes help
to to get good points okay that doesn't
look like a quick point but at least
it's a pretty active position with the
two bishops see - were singing okay and
now I'm trying to press on the F pawn
winning this it's very likely actually
we actually played Ruby f6 better okay
then the HP can you know check here and
now I'm pinning him on the back rank
maybe I can play Bishop f4 also
instantly but maybe M you can win a
couple of moves before I do that when a
couple of Tam beam white cannot do much
about this anyway and now I'm I could
also play yeah this is this is good
enough it's the play Bishop b2 okay this
is just a winning bishops endgame Bishop
f6 now okay threaten to to exchange
bishops and I was pretty optimistic with
the willing the winning part but it
should be with the h4 problem is
actually the h-bomb it's not so much the
extra pawn which is good but the the
passed pawn is just can just the main
thing here getting this this piece to f6
okay
when misplace while this gives me
another another free part I mean best
bone
so what's helpful of course the Kings
you follow us better so yeah well this
is enough but then came probably it
doesn't matter yeah it's the wrong color
but there's still a pony on the board
yeah yeah I'm one game away from the
tournament leader
oops of course d4 was it was planned
okay so I play the Hertz reverse or
something like this threatening before
winning a piece okay yeah come on let's
open up the position try to make this
bishop look a bit silly
should I take not sure I want to good
maybe this is not too bad if he takes on
default okay
he'd never thought about this not c4 I
was intending okay walked up here now
let's get rid of the annoying Bishop
from g4 okay this is helpful to the
exchange because I'm better on the
e-file
got the moves like 96 or 97 - to gain
gain control this is also an idea
attacking v6
it's not easy even to protect it okay
yeah maybe a check on will be one if I
go here he also needs to thought this
this looked looked really dangerous
maybe it isn't but it looks dangerous
yeah and now I'm Knight f7 who said as a
very close to checkmate can you attack
the bishop
I always have g3 now non-threatening h5
this was the idea it's not not made
now I'm Bishop f5 oops I was really not
paying attention to this this threat
okay let's give this check and now I
think it's mid next move right g6 Queen
g6 yeah this wasn't to clean victory I
mean he had some some stuff here all
right okay let's go through all openings
okay okay let's return to the Vienna I
had this time know a bit bit down and
when I think I played this move h2 h3
looks very slow okay I'm trying to try
to very quickly open up the position
against his uncounseled position here
Queeny for Piero p8 and I'm threatening
d3 now
d 3:24 op8
and now I'm can take on f2 oh yeah well
good with both pieces actually this
isn't bad also rupee 8 so possible and
you create ya frustra p8 maybe maybe I
shouldn't have I but I can actually take
here I can take here 25 93 93 and I'm
McQueen up yeah what I've got a bit
scared at first at 95 with some stuff on
f7 but okay route 65 was a simple
solution right don't for something
different yeah okay I try to play on the
on the g4 square
yeah I'm not sure maybe he's got a
really bad connection
the idea is to control d5 really this is
surprising
they don't have whoo and maybe I don't
don't have any any meaningful discovery
let's go here I can also um flame yeah
now I can take and 94 unmasking this is
Bishop so what the question is now I
came but if I take on c6 with the bishop
you can actually take on d4 right
okay let's take here and now when try to
win c5 but but slowly not hurrying
things yeah okay then I take this one
the idea is to I'm thinking too long
about stuff like we take these six
probably completely unnecessary
yeah now the idea is to go to the king
with a king to eat to protect d2 and
then try to okay here immediately every
chance or exchanging a good mood I want
I want I want to I get to to f7 he
should be 5 c4 would be very nice if I
would be able to to play that he
probably I thought he maybe needs to I
cannot really prevent it and now it did
gets very very very annoying okay he
wants to play some counter-attack with
Bishop e1
I want to do is get the bishop to g8 and
have this mating idea on on age 7 so
that he so that he cannot move the
bishop and then I want to advance the
pawns f3g form yeah this is very
annoying to defend whoops
whoops yeah he's still in a meeting net
Rock D 2 D 1 D 1 H 1 row page 1
don't move against this and this was
funny
I wasn't intended of course we came ok
in the French again yeah g5
can play this in all kinds of positions
and the French defense nowadays here it
is I'm not sure about the current state
of of theory at I'm not sure that it was
pretty okay for a while I think for
black but not too not sure about the
current state of affairs well this was
played too quickly by me really how do i
how do I place my King don't like that
yeah now a 3 mm and this looks like a
very stupid game by me hmm
got a bad King and a very very strangely
placed rook on on a form
yeah this is really a crap position
looks like looks very am NOT very
ammonius I will try to trick him a bit
queen h5 g4 with an attack on the rook
try to confuse him rook is still hanging
okay and if you move the bishop now I
have almost okay here up g3 almost hmm
but I can take on a three now right
still don't like this it looks very
messy enter but probably a black is okay
now
yeah threatening on them AG to a deaf to
if he takes with the Queen on age three
I can take F to yeah I think it's
winning now this was a shaky game I mean
I didn't have didn't have any control
and this especially with with the
terribly placed King but made at the end
and I'm about 20 points up ahead I mean
yeah sometimes you can get quick wins
here with 90 f7 I'm I admitted to just
the trick but always interesting to try
hmm can you take them I guess not but
what else is the sense then of this okay
it's not not correct but still
interesting to try
yeah it's not not really um for
compensation I mean must be honest about
that um it's still a bit tricky though I
in Bishop c4 Bishop c4 coming now Knight
d5 I can probably take only six with the
rook yeah I mean not not much not much
else I need to take what what he offers
me if you take on f6 now is this
possibility or maybe just here yeah just
him if he takes then his his knights on
yeah this is problematic now the only
issue is here also I need to be careful
about the back rank Queen d1 would be
would be a mate I'm not sure what he's
doing now actually because I'm I'm just
can just take it here done should I give
this check don't know let's just grab
grab everything so I'm Tony also this
and then Bishop III should be pretty a
pretty good control loop c1 and then the
C pawn
yeah this wasn't the greatest technical
play ever yeah at least I'm catching up
on the clock I mean the position should
be okay oh it seems that the tournament
is actually over I didn't pay much
attention to the time and well stating
this second place Jesus second place
what happened
I named at the end I mapped 20 points
almost down yeah
no idea I took too long for me to win
this game probably yeah was some on
first or second all the time some a bit
disappointing I mean it didn't play too
too badly I think yeah I hope you
enjoyed it
some entertaining game something and I
also yeah I also started to two minutes
late assault so not helping with this
narrow finishes yeah okay I hope you
enjoyed it and I'm back soon with some
other content Cheers